Democrats become even more radical as
Joe Biden prepares to jump into the 2020
race Ilhan Omar another fresh-faced so
much freshness and faceless resets her
anti-semitism clock back to zero and we
check the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
oh man a million things to get to today
we're gonna get to all of it first let's
talk about Congress
okay Congress is full of people who
don't know what the hell they're doing
but want to control your lives and they
also are not interested in
circumscribing their own power the way
the convened the Constitution was
designed to do but this is why we need
to take control of Congress once again
and it's why I'm a big believer in
calling a convention of states where we
the people can propose amendments
yes amendments that could force term
limits on Congress for example and make
them balance the budget we've got to
stop these idiots before it is too late
because they obviously are not
protective of their own power from the
executive and also they don't care about
limiting the the power of the government
at all this is why we need to restore
the checks and balances that the
Constitution provided for originally but
have been over it in my administrative
government for the last century can you
imagine the look on the faces of these
Congress people when they realize that
they have been circumscribed once again
in their power by amendments to the
Constitution this is why calling a
convention of states is the only way to
get the job done they're already 3.8
million people with us on this more
every day join me and my friend Mark
McClure go to convention of states comm
slash men to sign the petition today
that's convention of states calm slash
man I keep hearing from folks that
convention of states could become a
runaway convention that's not how the
article five convention works it still
requires confirmation by two-thirds of
the state's 38 states have to be there
and they have to confirm it so there's
that also people say well you know
amendments to the Constitution could
hamstring Congress too much is that
really what you're worried about at this
point in time seriously
convention of states calm slash Benza
sign the petition today go check it out
right now okay so big news we get to
update our list of candidates for the
2020 race for the Democratic side
joining the race are about to join the
race is of course Joe Biden we've pulled
some theme music for Joe Biden since we
have theme music for everybody else
here's some Joe Biden theme music
yes that guy he's about to join the 2020
race according to the hill he is
basically setting up all of his campaign
apparatus in New Hampshire in South
Carolina according to the hill in recent
weeks the former vice president's
longtime adviser stever Shetty and Mike
Donnellan have led a string of meetings
with potential aides to fill out the
campaign if Biden makes a decision to
enter the race according to various
sources wit that whenever the VP makes a
decision we'll be ready to go said one
source with direct knowledge of the
planning Greg Schulz was run by Daan's
PAC American possibilities and served as
his political director in the White
House is expected to be the campaign
manager apparently Mike Donilon is
expected to play the role of chief
strategist Kate Bedingfield's who was
Biden's communications director in the
White House is also expected to run his
communications shop longtime advisers
have been talking to other Biden alumni
for other press jobs now if Biden
doesn't get Barack Obama's endorsement
he's going to have a bit of a rough ride
here because he has outflanked on his
left by Bernie Sanders and his
outflanked on the intersectional side by
Kamala Harris so the early polls that
have him up there been I've been around
through several presidential election
cycles with open primaries and what you
see is that very often the person with
the highest name recognition leads
initially and then immediately falls
away as soon as the competition actually
begins Biden does not have a massive
lead in places like New Hampshire he's
up like 26 22 on Bernie Sanders in some
of the polling were he to declare he
might jump to 30 but by no means is
Biden the prohibitive frontrunner inside
the Democratic Party and he knows this
which is why Biden is constantly playing
both sides of the fence here's what I
mean so Joe Biden does this routine
where he says I'm friends with people on
the other side of the aisle I'm friends
with people on the other side of the
aisle that there are good guys you know
I believe in a better kinder gentler I'm
not like Donald Trump I'm not a
polarizing political figure forget about
the time I called Mitt Romney basically
a would-be slavemaster forget about the
time I said he wanted to put black
people back in Chains forget about all
of that now I'm a really good guy and
that's because I like people on the
other side I mean that's what that's
what politics is all about now what's
amazing is that Joe Biden then gets
called out by his own side and he runs
screaming from his own bipartisanship so
here's what happened in the last 24
hours with Joe Biden it really is
telling about the state of American
politics people are constantly talking
about you know Donald Trump being so
radical so extreme so polarizing so mean
to his political opponents and Joe Biden
you know he he longs for a better time I
remember at John McCain's funeral he got
this from Joe Biden him going out there
and saying yeah John McCain and I we got
along gangbusters we were just we were
just the best of friends and we were
really nice to each other and every so
often you see this right Elijah Cummings
with Mark Meadows doing the same thing
oh well you know we're really good
friends I know mark Meadows isn't a
racist but when people on the Left are
called out by their own side they will
not step forward to defend people with
whom they are purportedly friends very
often it's pretty rare it's pretty rare
I mean I said even on my birthday this
year for example I talked with a lot of
folks on the left that I consider
friends many of them would text me or
direct message me on Twitter saying
happy birthday and would not do so
publicly specifically because they were
afraid that they would get blowback from
their friends and this is not a rarity
that is confined to presidential
politics it is true across the board
here's what I mean so Reid Epstein who's
a reporter for Politico he tweets out in
Omaha Joe Biden calls Mike Pence a
decent guy our vice president this is
very bad Joe Biden must never
acknowledge Mike Pence as a human being
according to the radical left Joe Biden
acknowledging Mike Pence is akin to
saying he agrees with Mike Pence and we
all know that Mike Pence is a vicious
bigot and homophobe who wants to put gay
people in reeducation camps or something
so Cynthia Nixon he failed gubernatorial
candidate in New York against Andrew
Cuomo she tweeted out Joe Biden you just
called America's most anti LGBT elected
leader a decent guy please consider how
this falls on the ears of our community
and then she also acted Biden's wife to
make sure that Joe Biden would see her
tweed so he can't be a decent guy
because you disagree with him on
same-sex marriage he's a bad guy so Joe
Biden then responds to Cynthia Nixon and
he says you're right Cynthia I was
making a point in a foreign policy
context that under normal circumstances
a vice president wouldn't be given a
silent reaction on the world stage but
there is nothing decent about being anti
LGBTQ rights and that includes the
vice-president ah so in the end Joe
Biden is saying you know what you're
right Mike Pence not a decent guy
actually a very bad guy because he
disagrees with me on all of the LGBTQ
politics so I agree with since
I've been called out I apologize for
ever saying that Mike Pence is a decent
guy there this is what poisons our
politics this right here is what poisons
our politics Joe Biden is a national
leader like it or not and him coming out
and saying that Mike Pence is a decent
guy well that should be normal politics
I'm old enough to remember when John
McCain's added about Barack Obama and
Mitt Romney did it about Barack Obama
Democrats don't do this for people on
the other side they just don't Democrats
at high level Joe Biden is supposed to
be king bipartisanship over here and the
minute that he's called out by a radical
like Cynthia Nixon then as well you know
I guess Mike Pence isn't a decent guy I
guess he's a bad guy now because I need
Cynthia Nixon support you know there's
an actual term for this we call it
getting dupe lost yeah I know a little
bit about this for those who miss this
story is probably what six months ago
maybe there's an actor and director
named Mark Duplass very talented guy in
Hollywood and he was doing a new movie
about gun control and the gun debate and
so he reached out through a mutual
friend and asked if he could come into
the daily wire offices and he asked if
he could talk with me for a little while
about the pro-gun position and I said
sure he came in we talked I gave him
maybe an hour and a half we just talked
about guns and gun control and the
various positions and we're pro-gun
people are coming from what the Second
Amendment means and all the rest and I
gave him a lot of time and as he was
leaving I said dude you may not want to
let people know publicly that you were
here because you're gonna get clocked by
your own side well about a month later
Duplass tweets out if you want to follow
somebody from the other side who's
honest and well intentioned you should
follow ben shapiro and he's hit with a
an inordinate number a wave a tsunami a
tidal wave of hatred from the left
saying ben shapiro wasn't a decent guy
do you think ben shapiro is a decent guy
for x y&z here's all the bad things we
think ben shapiro has ever said so
simply for saying I'm a decent guy with
whom he disagrees he gets hit with a
wave of response and then being a coward
mark Duplass backs off his original
comment deletes his tweet saying that
I'm a well-intentioned person and puts
out a statement saying that he stands
against racism bigotry sexism and
homophobia hey that is called being doop
last Joe Biden just do plastic Mike
Pence and here's the problem I think
this is an endemic thing to an enormous
number of people on the Left they are so
afraid of their own side eating them for
some
acknowledging the humanity of people who
disagree with them that they are willing
to dump those people under the bus at
the at the drop of a hat
it really is sickening I mean that's
sickening behavior I the vice president
he knows Mike Pence he knows my pensee
decent guy they may disagree on politics
but that does not change the reality on
the ground that Mike Pence is a decent
American who is well-intentioned even if
he invitin disagree I've been striving
in recent years it's really something
I've striven to do I've been striving to
try and grant the initial recognition of
people with whom I disagree the initial
recognition of their good intentions now
sometimes you can't uphold that
sometimes the intentions it's just not
possible I will get to Ilhan Omar in a
second sometimes it's not possible to
read people's comments other than as a
reflection of underlying animus but
there's a concept in Judaism called down
the calf's loose which means that you
are supposed to try and see people in
the most favorable possible light you're
supposed to treat them like human beings
and if we don't do that we can't have a
common conversation because if in the
end Joe Biden believes that Mike Pence
is a bad ill-intentioned guy there's no
conversation to be had then it's just
about clubbing him to death like a baby
seal Joe Biden got clubbed into shape by
Cynthia Nixon who's not even a
mainstream political figure in the
Democratic Party now there was I got an
email from a from a friend last and I'm
not gonna mention whom this is a person
who was on the left and this person
emailed me and said you know is the
conservative movement into this person
was was watching CPAC and was noticing
that there are some people who are sort
of fringy at CPAC and this person was
saying do you think that the
conservative movement is unusually
susceptible to grifters
do you think the conservative movement
is unusually susceptible to people who
take advantage of conservatives because
there are a lot of people in the
conservative movement who rely on purity
tests meaning that it's very easy to get
people to buy into your program when you
say things like people who disagree with
me are insufficiently pure therefore
come around to my side and I said to
this person know this exists on all
sides of the political aisle but it
certainly exists on the left because
what just happened there is Joe Biden
throwing the sitting vice president of
the United States under the bus as an
even decent human being just because
Cynthia Nixon a radical on every in
every sense of the word a radical says
the job
and should not even make absolutely
anodyne milquetoast comments about Mike
Pence being a human being that's really
sick stuff and it's bad for our politics
it destroys our politics in fact so Joe
Biden is a weakling he's a moral
weakling and he demonstrated that in
front of the world nobody's gonna pay
attention of course because if you hate
Mike Pence or what my pen stands for
then you also don't believe he's a human
being but if we don't get to the point
where we acknowledge the people on the
other side or at least human beings or
that they can be human beings and that
simple political disagreement is not a
mark of bigotry animus and hate there's
not gonna be a republic for very long in
this country if you really believe that
your opposition is innately motivated by
bigotry and hatred why exactly would you
respect their vote why would you respect
their right to free speech why would you
respect their right to congregate and
associate you wouldn't if you think
everybody on the other side is a Nazi
then you start treating them like Nazis
and that's not that's not a good thing
there aren't a lot of Nazis left in
America but if we start treating each
other like the other side is a Nazi and
you can punch a Nazi rights are
endangered rights are endangered and so
is our our common social fabric and get
some more of the 2020 Democratic
presidential race in just one second
first let's talk about the best holsters
you can buy We the People holsters they
offer custom-made holsters all produced
right here in the United States they
design all their holsters in-house which
means they don't use any third-party
molds for their holsters instead they
design every unique mold in Las Vegas in
order to best fit each and every firearm
absolutely perfectly we the people
holsters even have their own 3d design
team they measure every micro millimeter
of their guns to ensure the perfect fit
it's not just enough to have a good gun
if you have a concealed carry permit you
need a good holster their unique
intuitive clip design allows for you to
easily adjust both the cans and ride of
your holster the cans is the angle and
the right is how high or low it sits on
your waist so that will fit comfortably
and securely at all times every holster
also has adjustable retention which is
signaled with a click sound which lets
you know that your firearm is securely
in place here enough to worry about that
thing falling out custom printed designs
in-house they've got thin blue line thin
red line the Constitution camo an
American flag they have more designs
coming out each and every month we the
people holsters they start at just 37
bucks apiece which is a great price for
a fantastic holster every holster comes
with a light
time at guarantee every holster ships
for free and if it's not a perfect fit
send it back for a refund I mean there's
a great product We the People holsters
comm /ban when you enter promo code been
at checkout you get ten bucks off your
first holster so that means it's as low
as 37 bucks and shipping is free with an
additional ten bucks off using my promo
code Ben again that's We the People
holsters comm slash men promo code Ben
at checkout for ten bucks off exercise
your second Amendment rights in the
smartest possible way get a weave the
people holster its We the People
holsters comm / Ben and use promo code
Ben to get 10 bucks off their holsters
which started like 37 bucks with Free
Shipping so that's a solid deal for a
fantastic american-made holster go check
them out right now ok so it's not just
Joe Biden who is radical it is beta
O'Rourke so beta dudes ready to run yo
do we have some beta with you music I
think that we need some I can't I can't
handle it without it do we have it guys
oh no no
[Music]
bata is ready to skateboard into the
2020 race according to Oregon law when a
US Senate bid comes up short the losing
candidate typically must pump the brakes
on his or her ambition the next move
tends to be sideways to run for governor
or maybe state AG or backwards a House
of Representatives seats that's not true
for betta
he lost his attempt to move up in the
Senate last year and then became a
national political star because the
media decided that he was a hero
O'Rourke told The Dallas Morning News on
Wednesday a me that's his wife and I
have made a decision about how we can
best serve our country we are excited to
share it with everyone soon and then he
ruled out running for Senate against
John Cornyn the other senator in Texas
so he is famous for skateboarding and
riding bicycles and generally being a
rad dude so he's going to be running as
well so that's very exciting I know
everybody is pumped up about bait out
he's kind of a second tier candidate if
you have to rank the candidates right
now you have to rank them at the top
Biden Sanders Kamala Harris bado is a
set top of the second here is where you
would put bait over a pretty obvious VP
pick if Kamala Harris wins the
nomination
speaking of which Kamala Harris gets
herself in a little bit of trouble so it
turns out that Kamala had tried to
rewrite history with her own policy do
we have some qumola Harris
theme music because it's actually
fitting there it is
so nark Kamala Harris who has undercut
her support with her own base because
her history was basically being an Ag
right like national prosecutor well
according to PolitiFact she actually
lies about her own record now they say
presidential candidate and US senator
Kamala Harris has made protecting
undocumented youth the top priority
during her time in the Senate she's been
a vocal supporter of the deferred action
for childhood arrivals program which
gives temporary protections to more than
700,000 young undocumented immigrants or
dreamers brought to the country as
children but on the campaign trail in
Iowa this past weekend Harris made some
questionable statements about a 2008 San
Francisco policy that reported
undocumented youth to federal
immigration officials upon their arrest
by local police at the time Harris was
the San Francisco DA and she supported
the policy which didn't take into
account whether the youth were actually
found guilty of a crime meaning as soon
as they were arrested ice was notified
and then she lied about it now that's
actually the right policy the right
policies that ice should know when
people are accused of a crime and are
also illegal immigrants but she lied
about it
so she was asked could you give us some
insight on how when for whatever reason
you were supporting this policy that was
essentially handing over undocumented
people to ice before they had been
convicted what's changed on that how did
you come up with those changes Harris
said that ended up being an unintended
consequence of the policy and I did not
support that consequence of the policy
and I believe that policy has since been
changed because it was not the intended
purpose of that policy that
unfortunately is completely false it is
completely false
former San Francisco County Supervisor
David Campos strongly opposed the policy
change he said that her statement just
doesn't fly he said with all due respect
to Senator Harris who has been a friend
I don't understand how she can say that
turning over young people and children
who are accused of a crime that later
turned out they did not commit was not
an unintended consequence of what was
going on it was precisely what was going
on and what we were trying to avoid when
we changed the policy you cannot rewrite
history and then so the policy was
reversed gavin newsom at the time was
the mayor of San Francisco and he
refused to enforce the reversal Harris
of course explained her position saying
there was an initiative that was written
by a Board of Supervisors that was
passed and there was opposition to that
but it did pass we're gonna have to wait
to see how the courts interpret it from
my perspective I think it would be in
conflict with federal law and we have to
follow the law so she knew full well the
consequences of the policy when she
endorsed it now she's reversing herself
PolitiFact which is a left-leaning
source if ever there was one they say
that the very purpose of the policy that
Harris endorsed is the one she says she
did not endorse they say Harris said she
feels strongly that undocumented
residents should be protected by an able
to trust local law enforcement that
sentiments however does not take away
from her mischaracterization of the goal
and fraud history of the 2008 policy she
supported and they rate Kamala Harris
has claims false this is Kamala Harris
does have an opening to her left Bernie
Sanders is gonna take that opening so
again I think that Joe Biden right now
has the most name recognition but there
is not a clear path to him to the
nomination unless he is endorsed by
Barack Obama who looks like he's gonna
sit this one out and the Democratic base
is too radical for Kamala Harris so
Bernie may be the guy my baito is sort
of hoping he can draw enough from these
various pools - to win the nomination
but it's gonna be a thing - Bernie
versus common law race maybe to the end
here with Biden trying to sneak up the
middle so that that's basically where
things stand meanwhile the Democratic
extremism is not relegated only to the
2020 race there's an unfortunate truth
anti-semitism has a home in the
Democratic Party it does a nil hen Omar
is praised by the by the higher-ups in
the Democratic Party despite saying
routinely anti-semitic things every two
weeks she has to apologize for
anti-semitism she's like that she's like
that chip from Futurama days since
accident and person who goes up and
nails up a one and then the one falls
down to reveal a zero days since
anti-semitism
Ilhan Omar it usually it's about ten and
then she has to reset it back to zero so
you'll recall that Ilhan Omar like
literally two and a half weeks ago
tweeted out it's all about the Benjamins
with regard to American support for
Israel as though the Jews and nefarious
Jews were paying off Americans to
support Israel and then she apologized
for it but not really she says no I
never apologized for being anti-semitic
and she she walked back her own apology
you've since apologized unequivocally
for the tweet you said rightly the
anti-semitism is real but just to be
clear I mean we're a few weeks on now I
mean what were you apologizing for was
it a badly worded tweet that you
apologizing for or was it for being
anti-semitic wittingly or unwittingly oh
absolutely not
I apologize for the way that my words
made people feel the reason I you know
and the purpose of the apology was to
make sure that the people who were hurt
felt understood and heard okay that's
that's that's an amazing non-apology
right there there's so fresh in so face
el han omar i mean on the cover of
Rolling Stone with Nancy Pelosi smiling
and grinning away open anti-semite open
anti-semite
so as Rasheeda Talib also an open
anti-semite who in the past has
suggested that American Jews are rife
with dual loyalty that American Jews
only like Israel because they're
actually secretly nefarious Jewish
workers for the Jewish state the drool
it can't be that American Jews are
supportive of Israel because Israel is
the home of Jews protecting Jewish lives
Israel is a democracy the only democracy
in the region and the place all over the
world where Muslims have the most rights
right that it can't be because of that
it has to because it has to be because
Jews are in farías secret agents of the
Israeli state that's really why all of
this is hetra schita Talib tweeted
something out about that three months
ago no apology from her shoot at sleeve
so open anti-semitism totally fine
inside the Democratic Party and Ilhan
Omar that that apology is an incredible
apology imagine that you get in a fight
with your spouse and you say something
truly terrible to your spouse I mean you
do essentially what el hunt Omar didn't
you see you call your wife a I
mean she's basically suggesting that
that American Jews and Americans who
support Israel are who can be
bought off with money that's basically
what she suggested when she said it's
all about the Benjamins
imagine you said your wife you know what
sweetheart you're a and then she
said well that's a pretty awful thing to
say how dare you that's that's an evil
terrible thing to say he said you know
what I apologize for how my words made
you feel no it's the thing you said
that's evil it's the thing you said
that's bad but ohan Omar never
apologized really for those comments but
we were all supposed to overlook that
because so fresh so face and of course
she can claim in her intersectional way
that she is minority woman from Somalia
who is a Muslim and therefore that's the
reason people are angry not because
she's a rabid anti-semite and she's been
consistently anti-semitic for
legitimately her entire career it's not
because of that it's because she's a
Muslim woman that people are very angry
at her weird weird because there are
lots of Muslims that I know who are not
anti-semitic and yet she is anti-semitic
so I have very very little faith that
this has anything to do with Islam I've
a lot of faith that it has to do with
her being a blatant anti-semite is the
reason why people are upset with her
okay so
Ilhan Omar yesterday doubled down on her
anti-semitism she was doing an event in
this way this is an event in New York at
oh sorry in is in Washington DC actually
at some bookstore she was doing it with
her schita Talib and at a certain point
here somebody in the audience yells out
it's all about the Benjamins and both
Rasheeda Talib and L hun Omar smile
according to press reports and then
Ilhan Omar explains
what she really wants to question is why
these why these nefarious Jews are so
loyal to Israel fossil fuel industries
or Big Pharma and not talk about a
powerful lobbying that is influencing
policy okay because the NRA is pushing
for a principle okay the Koch brothers
push for principles your suggestion
Ilhan Omar you anti-semite your
suggestion is that AIPAC and the Jews
broadly in the United States and
American Israel supporters in the United
States are not supporting Israel based
on principle they are doing so based on
dual loyalty they're doing so based on
tribal loyalty to Jews so in other words
if Israel decided to become a monstrous
dictatorship overnight and start
legitimately executing people that all
the Jews in the United States would call
for continued American support for
Israel because their principle free I
mean that's her essential contention her
essential contention is that American
Jewish support for Israel is not based
on any sort of principle it is based on
allegiance to a foreign power now think
about how absurd that is in the context
of other states I am a big believer that
the United States should stand with the
continued existence of Great Britain and
I think that the existence of Great
Britain is a great and wonderful thing
why because it is a country that has
stood for human dignity and Liberty
because it is a country that is
democracy because it is an ally of the
United States in real politic terms does
this mean that I'm I have Olli gence to
Great Britain that I have full
allegiance to the British I think France
should exist I think Germany should
exist and I think Israel should exist
too and I think the backing the
continued existence of the State of
Israel in the face of genocidal
terrorism is not in fact a violation of
America's priorities I think it should
be one of America's moral priorities
that does not indicate dual loyalty or
allegiance to Israel that's an insane
contention and an anti-semitic one
because again it is suggesting something
about Jews that you would not suggest
about anyone else it would ill hen omar
be willing
say the Catholics have to a loyalty to
Rome Catholics have dual loyalty to the
Pope
no Catholics have a sent a series of
religious principles that they hold dear
and those religious principles jibe with
their American citizenship because they
believe that America forwards certain
basic precepts that agree with the basic
precepts of Christianity this notion
that if you have certain we all have
certain fundamental moral principles
that dictate what we support and what we
do not but that's not what l hanuman is
claiming she's claiming that the jews
particularly don't have any central
moral principle for supporting Israel
there's no moral principle underlying it
it is simply dual loyalty or allegiance
to the government of Israel that is a
vile smear that has been perpetrated
against Jews for legitimately centuries
that the Jews are people apart who only
have tribal loyalty and they don't have
any underlying principles that leads to
a belief that the the Jewish people
should exist that essentially that
essentially Zionism is racism that
essentially belief in the Jewish people
as a whole has nothing to do with Jewish
principle and everything to do with
ethnicity that is a lie it's a
disgusting lie but it's a lie that she
perpetrated so she says all this and the
Democratic Party absolutely silent has
Nancy Pelosi said a word no is she going
to say a word
no she's going to appear on the cover of
Rolling Stone with a lie on Omar why
would she say a word I'm gonna hear
anything from Chuck Schumer that
supposed great friend to Jews in New
York no he's not gonna say a damn thing
because the Democratic Party is fully
comfortable with the intersectional
pyramid that suggests that if you rank
higher in terms of victimology in the
United States than the white Jews then
that means that you get to say whatever
anti-semitic things you please now
what's so hysterical about this of
course is that if you're going to look
by hate crime statistics and who at who
is most victimized who should be higher
on the intersectional pyramid in terms
of for example hate crimes Jews should
be higher than Muslims on the
intersectional pyramid because Jews are
victimized at twice the rate of Muslims
in the United States on a per capita
basis according to FBI statistics that
cuts no ice for folks on the Left who
believe that Jews are too successful to
be part of the intersectional pyramid
she was broadly speaking are too
successful therefore if they are
insulted by a group that is less
successful in the United States because
all unsuccess in the intersectional
pyramid is based on American
three it's based on the idea that
America is a vile terrible place that is
keeping people under its boot those
groups are allowed to victimize Jews and
yell about Jews and be as anti-semitic
as they damn well please
it's disgusting but don't worry Ohan
Omar's a fresh face and if we talk about
her anti-semitism it's only because
she's Muslim it really must because of
that it must be because of her religion
it's insane
by the way the radicalism of the of the
new fangled Democrats is just it's
tremendously extreme it really is and
the mainstream Democratic Party is
disappearing and it's it's leading to
it's leading us down a path where there
can be no agreement I mentioned earlier
Joe Biden basically suggesting you can't
be friends with a Republican that there
are no decent Republicans he called my
Pence a decent guy and then immediately
walked it back among the Democrats now
Democrats are going after not only
Republicans but each other so first of
all they continue to suggest that all
people they disagree with are vicious
racists Rasheeda Talib who again is just
just as vile as Ilhan omar and her
anti-semitism
you'll recall that a couple of days ago
during the michael cohen hearing michael
cohen was contending the president Trump
was a racist and Mark Meadows pointed to
pointed to a woman named Lynn Patton who
works with President Trump he said well
Lynn Patton works with President Trump
everyday and she's here and Lynn Patton
has given me this piece of testimony
saying that she's never seen President
Trump be a racist I said this was not a
good argument I said it was an emotional
appeal that I have a black friend is not
a real good response - you are a racist
all of that can be true rasheeda's
cwiebe went further
she said that Mark Meadows was an actual
racist for saying here's a black person
who knows President Trump and doesn't
think that he's a racist and deals with
him every day
Rashidah Talib said that mark Meadows
was a racist and that was a racist act
so here she and then she supposedly
apologized for that but just like Ilhan
Omar's apology it's not real she then
went on CNN and doubled down on it you
still today believe that that
congressman mark Meadows engaged in a
racist act I believe that that moment as
a person of color and not only myself -
I think three other of my colleagues had
mentioned how insensitive that act was I
think all of us I mean even folks at
home kind of gasped when that actually
happened I think if we want to talk
about race in this country that was not
the way to do it so in other words she
says that dad still was a racist act to
mark medal parts
painted in racism by saying here is a
black woman that I know who works with
President Trump and she can testify the
President Trump has never acted in a
racist way toward her why is that racist
well supposedly because Mark Meadows was
engaging in a form of tokenism it's very
weird when the left will suggest the
tokenism is occurring so the left will
suggest the tokenism is occurring when
for example Mark Meadows says here's a
black person who knows President Trump
but tokenism is not occurring when
Michael cone asks how many black people
are on presidents Trump's staff as
though if he had a bunch of black people
working for him that would also be a
defense against racism
so tokenism only works when the left
says that it works it's an in aptly
applied label also it's a little bit
insulting to a black woman Lynne Patton
to suggest that she was willing to stand
there and be used as a token of her race
Lynne Patton immediately responded along
those lines was what Lynne Patton had to
say about Rashida talib what I'd like to
ask the congresswoman from Michigan is
you know why does she take the word of a
self-confessed perjurer and criminally
convicted white man over a black female
who's highly educated rose up through
the ranks of one of the most competitive
companies in real estate you spoke
before 25 million people at the
Republican National Convention and now
works in one of the most historic
administration's in history and so to me
that would be my question that's more
racist than being put up there as a
quote-unquote prop okay yeah calling her
a prop that is a bad thing right that's
not the that seems pretty racially
charged didn't matter
AOC then defended her fellow fresh-faced
all the fresh faces defend each other
they're fine with their each other's
anti-semitism or the sort of racism that
reeks the intersectional racism that
reeks off of them
AOC tweeted out total bravery from
Rasheeda Talib as she reminds the nation
that tokenism is racism so again it's
not racism if you have a bunch of if you
ask how many black people do you have in
your office as a proof of your non
racism it is racism if you say here's
how many black people I have in my
office to prove that you're not a racist
mm-hmm also bravery has certainly
changed its definition Rashida to lead
is so brave I mean just like Normandy
just like Normandy calling calling
Republicans racist these days I mean
talk about taking the risk Michael
yes hey in a second we're gonna talk
about what else
AOC is doing to help out these supposed
moderates left in her party well gets
that in just a second first 9 to 9 999 a
month means you subscribe to daily wire
and that means they get the rest of this
show live you get two additional hours a
day you can ask questions during the
breaks you can join our chat room which
apparently is always a lot of fun my
producers watch it for good questions so
go check all of that out ninety-nine
dollars a year means that you get not
only the annual subscription but also
this the very greatest and beverage
vessels the leftist tears hot or cold
tumbler and you know what comes along
with that the ability to appear on the
show so today we are featuring a daily
wired premium subscriber we want to give
a shout out to a different subscriber
every week as a thank you for helping
support the daily wire although let's be
honest we are already giving you folks
way more than you deserve
really this week's shout-out goes to
Samantha at Sami girl 417 on Twitter
Samantha starts her day with a little
extra freedom sipped from her leftist
ears tumblr samantha is as American as
they come with the grand old flag in the
background thanks for being a subscriber
samantha and thanks for your service
looks like Samantha's in the military so
you are awesome you're awesome if you
want to receive a shout out and
experience the pure bliss but samantha
is likely experiencing at this very
moment you have to be an annual
subscriber and you have to post a photo
of your tumblr on either twitter or
instagram with the hashtag leftist two
tiers tumblers hashtag leftist two tiers
tumblr you can even be in the photo if
you would like get creative we like it
when you make us laugh entertain me and
then maybe you'll make it on the show
Samantha you are awesome that is a great
photo love it so go check that out
hashtag us at leftist ears tumblr if you
want to appear on the show also make
sure that you subscribe over at youtube
and itunes when you do then leave us a
review you also get access to our Sunday
special a day early this week sunday
special features the awesome Dan
Crenshaw I'm going to admit then we arm
wrestled I lasted longer than I thought
I would against the former Navy SEAL I
will not say that it went great for me
but in any case Dan Crenshaw is on the
sunday special becomes the Saturday
special when you subscribe to go check
that out right now we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so House Democrats are now dividing
in on themselves it's not just that
Democrats have become radical and
attacked Republicans as racist and bad
people at every turn
well engaging in some of the most racist
anti-semitic behavior I've seen in
modern American history not just that
the the radicals in the Democratic Party
are now trying to eat their own
according to the Washington Post House
Democrats explode in recriminations as
liberals lash out at moderates by the
way they're not liberals they're
leftists lashing out at liberals okay
they're not there no moderate Democrats
left in the Democratic Party basically
so those are liberals and then there are
the leftists who are censorious woke
schools who are trying to shut down
members of their own party Mike de bonus
is reporting he says House Democrats
exploded in recriminations Thursday over
moderates bucking the party with liberal
representative Alexandre Ocasio Cortes
threatening to put those voting with
Republicans on the list for a primary
challenge as though AOC has any weight
at all in the last in the last election
cycle she endorsed a bunch of other
people and it did not work it was just a
giant fail for her virtually all of them
were defeated in a closed-door session a
frustrated Speaker Nancy Pelosi lashed
out at about two dozen moderates and
pressured them to get on board or either
a team or not and we have to make that
decision Pelosi said according to two
people present but not authorized to
discuss the remarks publicly but Ocasio
Cortes the unquestioned media superstar
of the freshman class up the ante
admonishing the moderates and indicating
she'd helped liberal activists unseat
them in the 2020 election Corbin trends
a spokesperson for AOC said she's
putting her colleagues the Democrats she
told her colleagues the Democrats who
side with Republicans are putting
themselves on a list oh this isn't gonna
go poorly at all this is gonna go great
apparently AOC and her other leftist
colleagues are targeting the
quote-unquote moderates by the way those
moderates now include apparently people
like Dianne Feinstein one of the most
left-leaning members of the Senate in
American history in the those moderates
include people who exist in purple
states it's really funny there's a lot
of talk about how the tea party had made
the Republican party more radical how
people have been primary moderates had
been primary and replaced with with less
traditional candidates who are pure
ideologically and how bad that was I'm
missing that same sense of recrimination
from the media when AOC an open
democratic socialist who is a member of
the DSA
when she says that she's going to
cleanse the party with fire triggering
the blow up on Wednesdays votes on a
bill to expand federal background checks
for gun purchases 26 moderate Democrats
joined Republicans in amending the
legislation adding a provision requiring
that ice be notified if an illegal
immigrant seeks to purchase a gun that
infuriated liberals why would that
infuriate liberals because they're not
liberal they're insane
why would if an illegal immigrant tries
to buy a gun why should I snot be
notified so in other words Democrats
believe that if an American citizen
purchases a gun that should basically
not be allowed but an illegal immigrant
tries to purchase a gun ice shouldn't
even know about it
the Democratic in fights were in
fighting reflects a fractured caucus and
a diverse freshman class with dozens of
moderates elected in districts president
Trump won in 2016 at odds with
hard-charging liberals the split has
exposed divisions among Pelosi and her
top lieutenants Majority Leader Stinney
Hoyer of Maryland and Majority Whip
james Clyburn South Carolina over the
party strategy to keep its newfound
majority it's gonna get uglier inside
the Democratic Party because again the
radicals have control of the tiller
Nancy Pelosi may just be along for the
ride or maybe she's gonna have to fight
a OC for the actual for the actual
control of the party whatever it is
there's no question the Democratic Party
has lost what is losing whatever
moorings in reason are available and
that means moorings and in a social
fabric and listen the right is not
immune to this
certainly not I've been very critical of
Republicans this week on a variety of
issues but let's be clear what the
Democratic Party is doing and embracing
the most radical form of their base is
deeply damaging not just to the
Democratic Party overall I think we need
two viable parties but deeply damaging
to the country because that radical base
is firmly convinced that people on the
other side are bad human beings who must
be destroyed at any cost and believe
that they can say anything in the
pursuit of that destruction alright time
for the mailbag so joe says hey Ben my
girlfriend and I got into a debate on
whether or not anxiety is a sin I know
it states in the Bible that we are to
put our trust in God and if we don't
we're questioning God's plans as someone
who suffers from a panic disorder I was
a little off put by the idea that I was
sitting over something I had no control
over so my question is can you separate
a panic anxiety disorder from sinful
anxiety thanks love the show listen I
you know as a Jew I'm not a big fan of
the idea that your feelings are
typically a sin I think that usually
your actions are
Judaism is more of an axe based religion
than a faith-based religion in the sense
that facts don't care about your
feelings and acts don't care about your
feelings so sinful sinful anxiety I
would assume would be taking measures
that demonstrate a lack of faith in God
in some sort of fulsome fashion but yeah
just being anxious over the future I
think is sort of a natural part of the
human condition trying to fight it is
gonna make your life better trying to
trying to be more accepting is gonna
make your life better there's a phrase
my dad taught me many years ago when I
had a little bit of anxiety in law
school I didn't like being away from
home I didn't like living in an
apartment by myself I lived at home
during college and so I you know used to
get anxious being by myself 3,000 miles
away from my family
and he used to say acceptance is
relaxation and that is a basically
religious principle that you have to
sort of accept the reality of what is
but as far as anxiety itself being a sin
I think it's something that can be
fought without it necessarily being a
sin I tend to think of sin as activity
not as feelings now again if you allow
the feelings to dominate your life you
the part of your life that you can
control then you may be veering into sin
but I don't think that the feeling
itself is sinful Nicola says I was
recently a part of a discussion about
abortion I wasn't sure how to combat
this question where do we draw the line
in terms of what is okay to use his
birth control such as the morning-after
pill I'm interested to hear your
response
so the basic pro-life position on this
is that one's conception has taken place
anything that ends the chain of creation
of human life is in fact abortion and
not birth control so condoms for example
our birth control and not abortion
there's been no conception yet the sperm
is separate from the egg there's been no
new DNA form there's been no inception
of human life but if you're talking
about the morning-after pill that
prevents for example implantation right
I'm still I believe that that's
generally the morning-after pill does
there are some people who suggest that
it prevents conception itself again if
it were to prevent conception
I think that's not abortion if it
prevents implantation I think that that
is more like abortion Michelle says a
friends and I were discussing how Amazon
doesn't pay taxes and even though I
pointed out they do collect sales tax it
got me thinking why should there why
should we tax it businesses at all it's
one thing to tax people who in theory
use the road school safety net etcetera
the taxes provide wouldn't it be better
to encourage businesses to keep all
their profits and put the money back
into the business expand or even give
higher wage
when the economy grow faster that way or
are there enough loopholes that most
businesses don't pay taxes and Amazon is
just the fall guy at the moment well
loopholes don't when people use the
phrase tax loopholes that's not a phrase
that really exists what they mean is tax
deductions so if you have a tax
deduction that is not a loophole it's
just that some people don't have the
same deductions as others that's just a
fact of life right some people have a
mortgage deduction some people don't
have a mortgage deduction if you rent
you don't have a mortgage deduction does
the person with the mortgage deduction
have a tax loophole no that's called a
mortgage deduction amazon uses whatever
deductions are available to it as far as
the idea that taxing businesses is bad
for the economy of course that's true
which is why one of the most fascinating
things about the Nordic countries that
the left so loves
is that their corporate tax rates have
generally been lower than America's
corporate tax rates which is why they
can still support this massive social
welfare state despite the fact that they
have high personal income taxes
businesses are still willing to invest
over there because businesses can still
make a profit over their case Sean says
hello in Parador Shapiro I work for NPR
in the wonderful state of Indiana the
Indiana Senate just passed a hate crimes
law which is significant because Indiana
is one of five states that has no hate
crimes law but the law has raised a
considerable amount of controversy
because the Republican senators stripped
away specifically protected
characteristics from the law such as
gender identity race and sexual
orientation instead the hate crimes law
allows a judge to determine the bias of
a crime more generally as you can
imagine my cheery co-workers at NPR
along with all forms of press in Indiana
and all the Democrats in the state are
furious that specific characteristics in
the bill are not mention everyone is
painting the Republicans as foolish weak
and parochial what is your take on hate
crimes laws so I think hate crimes laws
are garbage I don't see a rationale for
them every crime is motivated by a
certain level of hate and I don't see
why we should punish certain levels of
hate more than we punish other levels of
hate you are not in fact creating an
impetus for people not to be hateful
simply because there are hate crimes
laws on the books that I have seen no
evidence of that as far as the idea that
you're not going to name protected
classes I assume the reason you're not
naming protected classes is because you
don't want people filing hate crimes
legislation against you if you have for
example a religious bakery that says I
don't want to cater the same-sex wedding
and then someone says oh well that's a
hate crime or you're a business and you
don't hire a transgender person because
you're a religious Day School or simply
because you know
on a higher a transgender person for a
makeup job or something you should be
able to associate with whomever you want
and if people want to react to that by
boycotting you that's their problem or
not associating with you that's not
that's their problem as well the notion
of hate crimes allows the thought
policing of hate crimes laws is deeply
counterintuitive to basic American
freedoms then again that's not in favor
of hate or in favor of crime it is in
favor of a government that polices
action and not thought Nick says hey Ben
who do you think are the greatest song
lyricists of all time well I'm a big
musicals fan so the ones who come to
mind are folks like Cole Porter Oscar
Hammerstein is tremendously underrated
Stephen Sondheim of course as far as
sort of other lyricists Johnny Mercer is
a fantastic fantastic lyricist but again
I favor some of the old the old lyricist
I don't think any of the new lyricists
do anything of real import to be frank
Zachary says I've recently watched the
best of enemies the documentary about
the debates between gore Vidal and
William F Buckley during the 68 election
given that you're a conservative like
Buckley if a similar documentary were to
be made about politics today who would
be your Gore at all well I mean the
problem is that most folks who are
prominence on the Left are not
interested in actually having
discussions so it's difficult to find a
gore of at all I mean at least in 68
Buckley at all would get on set together
and then argue with one another it's
difficult to get people to do that on a
repeat basis these days there are people
with whom I disagree with whom I am very
friendly I mean Eric Weinstein is the
person who comes to mind he and I are
very friendly and he and I disagree on a
lot of stuff politically oriented but as
far as being just a screed driven non
fact-based person gore Vidal is pretty
indicative of left I think there are
plenty of folks like core of it all I
think they're very few like William
Buckley now Charles has hey Ben can you
explain the difference between a kippah
and a yarmulke is there a religious
significance to using one word instead
of the other the only difference is that
keifa is in Hebrew and yarmulke is in
Yiddish that's the only difference
so typically speaking the way that
Bertha docks Jews tend to we tend to
speak Hebrew more than Yiddish these
days although it depends I mean if
you're in the ascetic community
I assume that people use the word
yarmulke more often in my Orthodox
community virtually everyone calls her
to keep not not a yarmulke in
conservative and reform communities the
word yarmulke tends to be used a little
more frequently I Ashley says as you may
know the Missouri House represented
has perfected and passed the most
restrictive pro-life Bills in the
country I work as a legislative chief of
staff for a state rep that supports this
legislation per usual reps are in
support of this and they're receiving a
ton of emails in opposition but one of
them stuck out to me because this person
claims that anti-abortion laws are
anti-semitic please help me understand
her reasoning below as part of the email
just so you know abortion restrictions
and bans are anti-semitic Judaism
doesn't believe in the whole life begins
at conception well I'm not according to
Rabbi Moshe Feinstein not according to
our own myths enstein these are all
orthodox very very prominent rabbis of
the last century the basic Jewish
position is that abortion is the taking
of a human life and is unjustifiable
except in cases in which the mother's
life is in danger now there may be
dispensations that are given by
individual rabbis for a variety of
individual reasons those are called head
hairs but the basic rule is the rule
that I just stated and as far as the
notion that in the in the Talmud
suggests that that the that the fetus is
quote-unquote like water for the first
40 days moshe feinstein is an actual
Posay a person who gives Halak judgment
jewish law judgment has said from what
I've heard anyway that that judgment is
meant to reflect simply the the status
the sort of purity status of the woman
if she were to lose the baby at that
point that it doesn't count as a
miscarriage at that point for purposes
of purity that doesn't mean you can have
an abortion there are no Orthodox rabbis
of whom I know who believe that abortion
on demand is a thing none and by the way
I find it highly ironic when people who
are pro-choice suddenly start citing
rabbis as their rationale for why the
law should be pro-choice what happened
to your theocracy complaints what
happened to your whole we shouldn't
listen to these religious crazy people
let's listen to these other religious
crazy people what happened why is it
that we should defer to the rabbi's I
thought that you guys don't want to
defer to anybody religious weird hey
Brian says hi Ben I'm a veteran and my
main incentive for serving was the GI
Bill many people are advocating for free
college what do you think the effect
would be on a volunteer only military if
we take the GI Bill off the table
because we offer free school to everyone
this is a great question I mean
obviously some incentive for some people
to join the military is the capacity to
have their college paid for if everybody
is getting free college I assume that
recruitment would drop again you're
removing an incentive that's that's a
that's a real concern
Ishay says hi Ben I'm confused with the
current talk by aoc on the green new
deal
I thought her camp basically took down
the document and the frequently asked
questions claiming it was a draft in the
end however I do not see a new one so
are they pushing the draft or are they
playing if you say something enough
people will believe it without ever
putting up a supposedly final draft love
the trouble this is obviously true it
was not a first draft it was a final
draft it was put up it was idiotic
everybody made fun of it aoshi pretended
that she had been victimized by her own
staff there was no new draft put up I
pointed this out literally the day this
happened when a OSI suggested that it
was a first draft I said okay so where's
the final one like if I posted a draft
on a website of an article that a final
draft existed and I found out about it
we'd immediately take down the first and
put up the second this would not be
difficult but there is no new draft
because it's all bullcrap hey Lucy
absolutely meant what she said in that
ridiculous green New Deal document Shawn
says hi Ben
huge fan pens cheap hero 2020 for my
question regards the death penalty as a
pro-life conservative I often find
myself debating others on the right
regarding the death penalty being
pro-life I believe as it as in the First
Amendment case that the right to life
extends to all even the most evil among
us in society however those I debate
with commonly resort to moral relativism
the left-wing belief where I hear
phrases such as well these people are
evil so they don't deserve to live well
that's not moral relativism moral
relativism is a belief that there is no
such thing as evil moral relativism is
the idea that in any given situation
there is no better choice and no worse
choice all choices are equally
justifiable and equally moral depending
on your perspective that it's not moral
relativism to say that a person who
murders babies should be put to death
but a baby should not be put to death
that's not moral relativism that's
saying that people are responsible for
their actions the best argument against
the death penalty is that it is
unequally applied that it is applied
after too long that there's the
possibility of making mistakes those are
all good arguments against the death
penalty the principled arguments that
you should not execute anyone for any
reason is something with which I
heartily disagree if somebody rapes and
murders a five-year-old that person
shouldn't just die that person should be
put to death seven times and then burn
in hell for eternity Benjamins has been
often you guys at the Daily wire
complain about the double standards on
the Left what are the conservative
double standards we need to be careful
of well I mean obviously there are
people on the right who are willing to
justify behavior by President Trump they
would never they would never justify if
that behavior were on the left that is
the most obvious there are also certain
that I would say that on the right
there's a certain willingness to engage
in an affirmative action belief that we
ought to give more value to certain
opinions because of the speaker which it
which is something I generally disagree
with the identity of the speaker should
bear no relevance to the the efficacy or
use of what the person is saying there
are people on the right who again will
change their standards of objectivity
when it comes to folks on the left yeah
those are the ones that come to mind I'm
sure I could come up with ten more I
think that political partisanship as
I've said before is a hell of a drug and
I think that people are willing to blind
themselves to basic double standards out
of lack of ability to comprehend
cognitive dissonance let's see one more
do two two two Linda says hi from
Australia can you do a Jordan Peterson
impersonation actually I did one I went
to a Jordan event in LA he and Dave
Rubin invited me to stop by and I did a
little bit of a Jordan Peterson
impersonation it was more in content
than in than in style but I I walked
onstage and I presented Dave Rubin with
a cupcake because there was this big
controversy over whether I would bake a
cake for Dave Rubens wedding as a
religious Jew the answer is no Dave is
gay I'm not going to participate in the
same-sex wedding am I willing to bake a
cupcake or a cake for Dave sure I love
David he's great he's my friend why
wouldn't I bake a cake for him so I
brought a cake onstage and a cupcake
onstage and then I said that I had also
brought a cake for Jordan Petersen but
it was a metaphorical cake it was it was
so but he meant that's the importance of
the cake what you have to understand is
that a real cake is instantiated with
work and a reality that doesn't really
reflect the underlying hardship of life
cakes are too sweet
they they they don't really take into
account how difficult and bloody
important life is life is about struggle
life is about understanding that we work
and then we die but the work is what's
truly important and that's why a
metaphorical cake is so good until you
understand the struggle of the
metaphorical cake you don't deserve the
real cake that's more of a Content
Jordan Peterson impersonation I can't
really do the the accent I'm not great
with Canadian accent I mean I'm not
great with any of my impersonations
let's be frank about this and some of
them are slightly better than media
my Obama is pretty good but my Jordan is
is not great the content those is not
terrible okay time for a couple of
things that I like so thing I like
number one so my sister Abigail Roth
opened CPAC today and forget your
politics whatever your politics are she
is an immensely talented human being
here she was singing the star-spangled
banner to open CPAC so he is immensely
talented obviously she went to the
Metropolitan School of Opera on
scholarship she had a full scholarship
full ride at USC in Opera she's an
incredibly talented human being can
follow her on Twitter at classically
Abby and she does all sorts of kind of
makeup videos and and classical music
stuff and she really is an incredibly
talented person so she should go check
that out speaking of incredibly talented
people sadly Andre Previn passed away
yesterday Andre Previn is one of the
most talented people of the 20th and
21st centuries he was a pianist a
conductor a composer and he really
started early I mean he was already
working for the Hollywood studios while
he was in high school and arranging
music for here's a composer conductor
for MGM when he was 18 years old an
amazing career is in in classical music
he was responsible for arranging some of
the great MGM pictures of all time among
them I believe American in Paris so here
is here is Andre Previn playing and
conducting Rhapsody in Blue
[Music]
incredibly talented guy he won four
Academy Awards
he scored GG in 1958 he scored porgy and
bess
in 1959 you're not allowed to mention
porgy and bess anymore because that's
it's very bad even though it's one of
the great works of American art of all
time by George Gershwin we're not
allowed to mention porgy and bess
because it has to do with race and then
he also won Best Score for her
maladaptation or treatment for thermal
adduce and also for 1964 s my fair lady
immensely talented human being and also
a terrific composer so you can go check
out a lot of and reap revans work on
YouTube go check it out and tribute to
him today ok time for a quick thing that
I hate so final word on the execrable
Ilhan Omar who truly deserves the
accolade
I've called Michael Noel's execrable and
joke in jest L had Omar's truly
inexorable human being she proved that
today when she said that she would not
recognize the interim president of
Venezuela so just to get this straight
she's very much against Israeli
dictatorship and Trump's dictatorship
but actual dictators who slaughter
people in the streets and also make sure
their citizens eat dogs
those people should remain according to
ohon Omar at least in Venezuela we are
threatening intervention we're sending
humanitarian aid that that is in the
guise of you know eventually invading
this country and fellow Democrats unlike
the US government does and the Canadian
government does you don't support the
leader of the Opposition as being the
president right now not presently direct
absolutely not so by the way this is a
lie that the United States is on the
verge of military intervention in
Venezuela one of the reasons that people
are recognizing Hwang Fido is to create
an incentive for Maduro to leave she is
siding against that because she thinks
America is a nefarious force in the
world because she believes that Maduro
is more legitimate apparently than white
oh so she's prefer that pressure not be
applied it to Maduro she would prefer
that everything just be left alone but
we're supposed to believe that this
fresh face of the American Congress is
supposed to be good for the country and
she's good for American principles sure
sure but don't worry the Democrats
aren't too extreme in any way alrighty
we'll be back here later today for two
more hours this is why you should
subscribe
or alternatively we will see you here on
Monday and bring you all the updates I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19